les trains piste radicaux du 6 janvier
et les communards de 1870 ont-ils des
idéaux en commun ça c'est la grosse
question la réponse est à la fois oui et
non c'est à dire que évidemment les 30
pistes radicaux du 6 janvier
ils voient des communistes partout alors
que les communards de l'ismans 70-71 ils
sont très heureux d'être communiste mais
en même temps ces deux extrêmes
ces deux radicaux ils partagent une
radicalité ils partagent une détestation
des pouvoirs institués une détestation
de la démocratie représentative et une
détestation des élites et il aspire à
une démocratie directe une démocratie où
chacun pourrait s'exprimer tout le temps
pour décider de tout tout le temps
[Musique]